hello and welcome to big think live I'm
Jason gots and I'm here with Maddy grant
she's the co-founder of social fish a
social media consulting firm and the
co-author with Jamie nodder of humanized
how people centric organizations succeed
in a social world Maddy welcome to the
program thank you so corporations aren't
people has been a very common political
refrain by people disaffected with Wall
Street in the wake of the 2008 crash yet
your book suggests that corporations are
becoming more and more like people all
the time how is this the case and why is
it good for both companies and
individuals well actually at what we say
in the book is that corporations should
become more human all the time so I
don't know that we're there yet but what
we're seeing is that the deep changes
brought about by social media in the way
that we interact with companies and with
brands are actually really disruptive to
the way we traditionally work so if we
can incorporate some of these social
media things these human aspects into
how we work then will flourish as
companies in the future that's our
theory do you see some companies and
particularly I'm interested in an
established like you know uh steer kind
of classical companies that that are
adopting social media faster and more
effectively than others you know as a bi
one would expect it to be natural among
small silicon valley tech companies but
yeah there's a lot of adoption among
quite large companies obviously mostly
technology related companies like you
know IBM or dell but we're seeing every
single company in every industry
affected in some way large or small by
social media so the future is that every
single industry will be touched if
they're not already and some industries
are extremely disrupted already by
social media
so like what are some of the biggest
ways in which social media is disrupting
industry and why are people centric
organizations much more likely now to
succeed you know then them ones that are
not well the ways that companies are
disrupted have to do with the fact that
through social media we the people are
able to create and share and communicate
and collaborate and solve problems
without necessarily the traditional
structures that were in place before so
we can get our information you know
through search instead of going through
traditional channels for example so as
companies try and use this new which is
actually no longer really new but this
different way of communicating this very
two-way and they're trying to fit these
communication channels into traditional
marketing and communications and PR you
know which is because that's how we work
that's how they're used to operating but
we're finding that it doesn't work so
well that way you know people want to
too they want our organizations to be
more decentralized more transparent more
open more collaborative and those are
things that change at a very deep
internal level how we're used to working
okay are there industries that are so
opaque or just locked in or aware you
know the sort of public access to
information is is is so limited in spite
of these new tools available to us that
they are not likely to be affected as
quickly by social media I mean I could
see you know United Airlines or you know
a company that has is in a service role
having to worry about it a great deal
but what about like I know an insurance
company okay well actually interesting
because I happen to work with
associations so my social media
consulting firm deals specifically with
membership organizations but that means
that we work with a lot of trade
associations and trades are all kinds of
different industry verticals
so manufacturing real estate you know
you name it there's an association for
it right and at the end of the day every
industry has customers has people
whether it's b2b you know business to
business or b2c business to consumer
every industry is part of a network of
individual people and what we're
discovering through social media and
through these disruptive changes is that
connecting individual people within
these networks whether it's a business
that deals with business or a business
that deals with a consumer and is is a
new way of working basically so really
for it for everybody and sure there are
some companies that that may have less
need to to really think about social
media than others but we're seeing very
few that aren't affected I mean we work
with you know packaging machinery
companies and they there's they still
have staff and they still have customers
and they still have individual people
who work within their networks in their
systems gotcha and um so what you know I
would think that it when companies start
integrating we were paying attention to
social media initially there as you were
saying they sort of like make it part of
their PR and they might have you know
someone just tweeting things out etc but
how do they get beyond what it you know
do you have any sort of key tips for
taking it beyond just paying lip service
to social media by having somebody post
things on Facebook for example yeah and
it's it's not so much tips that I have
but what we're seeing is exactly why we
wrote the book so we're seeing these
social media hurdles for companies
trying to integrate social media into
their operations so for example you have
companies with different departments all
off doing different things you know
setting up Facebook pages and setting up
Twitter accounts and they're not
collaborate collaborating with each
other to to understand why they're doing
all of these things so that's one
example another example is you have a
bini that's thinking about social media
policies and trying to figure out who in
their organization can have a twitter
account and speak you know on the behalf
of the organization but they're worried
about you know giving this level of
public access to employees who may be
traditionally and never had that so we
see these as social media integration
hurdles and and what we're seeing is
that these are indicative of much deeper
organizational issues so in these two
examples one is that you have silos that
don't communicate or don't collaborate
you know so that's not a social media
problem that's like an organizational
development problem it's like a culture
change problem the other example with
policies maybe you don't actually trust
your staff you only trust your media
spokesperson you know so how do you
shift from a company that is used to
having one or two people who are enabled
to speak for the company to all of a
sudden having a thousand people enabled
to speak for the company it's it's again
it's a culture change it's an
organizational change so the tips that
we have are actually entirely related to
social media so social media is showing
us how to do these things and maybe it's
as simple as having a team of people who
collaborate you know one person from
each different Department who are
responsible for social media they're the
social media team but in just in the
fact of being a team that sits in
between these departments they start to
break down the silos you know or in the
policies example you set up social media
guidelines that are much more about
allowing people to to represent you
online as opposed to policing and
stopping all of your employees from from
doing these things so you use these
social media implementation or tactical
things in order to make some deeper
organizational changes that's very
interesting I mean so the you know it
would seem to me that a certain amount
of policing
is still necessary mean you talk about
having having teams working
collaboratively between departments I
mean if you have an organization that
you know a global organization I mean
even if it's a very good company right i
mean there there there are always PR
gaffes even among even when there's only
one spokesman spokesperson for the
company so i would think that you know
it's not necessarily a simple matter to
empower everyone within like a giant
company to to take over and speak for
the company may I think there's a lot of
risk involved yes there is a lot of risk
I think it is simpler than we think I
think there's more fear than there is
actual risk so that in what we would
call a human organization yes you take
that risk of letting potentially
everybody in your company speak for the
company but at the same time each of
those individual people are asked to
represent themselves as working for the
company so they're nobody's hiding the
fact that they represent the company and
if somebody makes a mistake especially
on social media which is very
fast-moving and fluid and conversational
somebody makes a mistake that's okay you
know there's it's it's not this huge
crisis that it could be if you know an
official media spokesperson says
completely the wrong thing I feel like
that's a different sort of old way of
thinking about risk at the end of the
day interesting in some ways maybe
companies increase their risk by
limiting their voice to a single
individual because the the fallout is
greater if that person makes you think
yeah the risk of not being out there not
having a presence you're not having
people representing you I think it's
greater than the risk of having lots of
people potentially okay so um for peep
for individuals who aren't as fluent as
they might be with social media how can
you know individuals not like both in
within their companies and outside of
them
can they take advantage better advantage
of some of these new tools to you know
of the power that that social media
gives us to make companies take action
to get things done to organize etc yeah
I think social media is very fast-moving
and the tools change all the time so
right now the big three our Facebook
LinkedIn and Twitter so for somebody
who's not a social media person who's
not really used to using social media
tools it's just about trying one of
these one of these obvious ones where
they will know people who are using them
and just see how they feel but you know
tomorrow it might be Pinterest Instagram
and something else that everybody is on
so it's not about learning a new tool
it's just about communicating with the
people around you in the way that they
communicate and there's a very kind of
natural evolution of these tools where
you know ten years ago it was only high
school kids on Facebook for example but
now my grandmother's on Facebook you
know so so that there shouldn't be any
fear of trying these tools and
especially as people become more and
more mobile use their mobile phones for
everything you know all of these tools
become very very easy and very natural
to use to stay connected with friends
and colleagues and and brands even so
it's just a matter of kind of going with
the flow really just seeing you know
what your friends are using what your
colleagues are using and for companies
encouraging people to try these tools is
important too so a company can say we
want to set up a google plus page just
to see what happens to see who finds us
that way who connects with us that way
and our employees therefore should just
check it out to try it and see if it
works for them and if it does and maybe
they could express interest in being on
our new social media team you know it's
it's all it's a little organic that way
and that's partly what a human
organization is able to do is to to take
advantage of these kind of organic
evolutions in the way that we
communicate and the way that we work
thank you so much for being with us
today Maddie grant yeah and we invite
our big think audience to visit
humanized book calm and to check back to
big thing calm to watch additional video
clips from our conversation with Maddie
and to find out about future live
interviews with our experts thank you
for watching
you